i love kirby welcome back to new
rockstars this is the big question the
show that gives you too much information
on why god has to constantly go to the
character creation screen every time he
wants to come walk around on earth and
harass us npcs just trying to live our
lives and not get fragged by the main
player all right we just we're trying to
live out here all right my name is mt
and i'm here today with offspring
producer my brother brandon hello mt
yes i'm definitely an npc i am not the
main player in this game my friend uh
i'm happy to be an npc though i'm the
guy in the town who's always got a good
joke for you when you walk up and you're
like i just need quest information i
have useless jokes that's all i got
i'm the uh npc gesture in the town i
know everybody
i'm crazy um
but anyway
what's our big question for today
brandon well mt in the latest episode of
moon night we learn more about how
khanshu uses his human avatars on earth
as a fist of vengeance but why does he
go to all this trouble dealing with us
annoying meat bags who don't want to
listen to him i don't want his voice in
our head and think he looks freaky and
it's scary we're scared in the elevators
we're screaming why doesn't he just come
down on earth and do things himself you
know what i mean take a page out of
thanos's book fine i'll do it myself
that leads us to this week's big
question why does khanshu need an avatar
why again we're not talking about avatar
the last airbender here we're not
talking about the blue people avatar the
the inferior avatar opinions i see you
know that's airbender i see you let's go
i
my head blue arrow like aang okay i have
the baldness for it so it's easy all
right yeah i'm an ang boy yeah team
amateurs
hey i'm team 3d blue people
anyway um but that is an interesting
question for sure and you're right for
whatever reason the gods of egyptian
mythology just can't come down to earth
and do what they want and this rule
doesn't seem to apply to some other gods
that we've seen in the mcu like the
asgardians that we've seen though
hanging around with the norse people
like some time in the past and the
celestials and in the second episode of
moon knight arthur harrow mentions that
kanchu was banished and he seems to
insinuate that this banishment is the
reason that konchu needs to use an
avatar in this case being you know mark
spector but can we trust what arthur is
saying here because we haven't finished
the series yet obviously we're only on
episode two so we don't know if what
harrow is saying is actually true
because that dude uh he kills old ladies
for fun yeah yeah you can't really trust
an old lady killer um usually no um but
he also claims to have been conscious
previous avatar again this could be a
misdirect so we're not 100 sure if that
is actually true that's a great point
empty because you know conscious is not
a great god but i don't trust anything
arthur harrow has to say and i don't
really believe i don't believe that
arthur harrell was his previous avatar i
don't i don't believe that either i
think he's he's just playing he's
playing steven for a fool you know
steven's scared he wants a little lentil
soup you know he'll he'll believe
anything arthur has to tell him because
he he's been going through all this
crazy stuff lately right this is true i
mean like hey if i'm just like this dude
who's like frazzled and has no idea
what's going on i'm and i'm arthur
harrow like i'm gonna try to manipulate
this dude right and just be like all
right you're trying to get that scarab
back that sweet sweet scary you know i
mean and then immediately kill him for
being annoying yeah
he's like he's like you don't get the
scarab okay i'm getting another dog out
of hell and i'm gonna kill this son of a
[ __ ]
no free soup no soup for you also like i
know you know you're you're a cult and
you wanna make the world a better place
and it's gonna be this fun free willing
place but like do we really have to
watch like nature documentaries during
lunch i mean seriously yo something is
going to put something more fun on the
street could watch like the wire you
know or watch uh better call saul i
don't want to have to watch nature
documentaries all the day imagine i just
walk
oh i'll join this cult we get to watch
the wire that's a good cult i'm in i'm
in baby
but is it just konshu who is forced to
use an avatar because we haven't seen
any of the idiad show up on earth just
yet and even harrow himself appears to
be working to bring a back ahmed so
perhaps she too cannot be present on
earth at this time in the comics it's
also established that khan shu's father
adam raw himself cannot enter the
earthly plane he also has to choose an
avatar to represent him also known as
the sun king which is you know very
interesting to me because there's this
whole theme of day and night between kid
cudi when of course kid cudi invented
the sun right um he did it
thank you
praise cuddy praise god yes raise cudi
the book of genesis and of course ra is
the child of the elder god gaia in the
marvel comics and she uh created adam
raw or raw to help her kill all the
other bad elder gods on earth who had
basically just turned into these
demon-type creatures and this is where
you know your catholics come in this is
like you're really not great types of
people this is like old old old-school
earth like very far back
like in the beginning like this is like
the old school like the original sort of
like marvel comics origins and ra did
just as his mama asked and went around
killing all these demons and absorbing
all of their powers until he himself
became this god-killing monster known as
the demagor and once he was done with
this task he flew away to the sun to
rest and recharge almost like you know
somebody else that we know from the mcu
who do we know who do we know that likes
to fly into the sun
[Music]
oh but yeah once he was done with his
task he flew away to the sun to rest and
recharge in around 65 million bc he came
back to earth as the demagor to kill all
of the dinosaurs who were controlled by
and giving power to the elder god set
who in my personal opinion might just
factor into the future of the mcu i
think we're gonna see some set stuff
rock killed all the dinosaurs
[Music]
that is yes that is very strange because
like i don't know what is beef was the
dinosaurs uh but like no i think that
sat was drawing power from these beings
yeah he was basically just taking all of
his food source away well i think too
part of it was like the dinosaurs
weren't
cutting it as like the main rulers of
earth right like it was like yeah this
isn't going well we're gonna give the
mammals a chance so guy is like hey son
i know i haven't talked to you in a long
time son my son and the son
my my baby boy and the murderer son uh
my murder i need you to come back and
kill all the dinosaurs the thing that
every child
throughout the rest of history will love
and adore i need you to murder them
because they're powering sex yes it's
like we need the jurassic park franchise
murder these dinosaurs that's true
empty in a world where the dinosaurs
live on and they don't go extinct and
somehow humans manage to make a a a go
at it and we grow we we get to where we
are and there's dinosaurs and humans
living together do you think we would
like dinosaurs as much or we'd be like
ugh if another if a different animal had
like gone and sinked and said the
dinosaurs like uh fish i don't know fish
went extinct right and we're just like
we're going to museums and we're like
ooh fish oh fish and we're making movies
about fish and how cool fish were
jurassic people yeah yeah they're making
god the whales they're making cartoons
they're making cartoons about like
robotic fish and stuff from outer space
oh man i wish i was alive when fish were
alive they would be so cool
hey man uh that's not too far off
hey
every couple weeks i wake up in a cold
sweat about that episode about
everything that's gonna go wrong
very shortly i will never forget that
episode from the one pq that stays in my
head i'm like oh my god we're screwed
nothing matters
but anyway on a lighter note eventually
raw would come back to earth again one
more time to create the heliopolitan
race of gods and so in the comics the
egyptian gods were created on earth but
then decide to leave with the pharaohs
start ruling things and they move to the
celestial heliopolis which is in a
dimension next to earth not actually on
earth it appears to be after this move
that raw is no longer able to enter the
earthly realm so could it be the danger
that his demi gorge form poses or
perhaps a deal he made with gaia after
moving to the celestial heliopolis it is
weird i i like this idea that yeah the
demigorg is like too dangerous to be on
earth now that like people are around
and all the dinosaurs are dead there's
no reason for him to be here anymore and
maybe gaia made that thing where it's
like yeah you guys can go live in this
little dimension and have do your thing
have your great little dimension but you
can't come back you're too dangerous and
like you could just to wipe out any of
the other gods and then raw and his son
konju would then go on to battle each
other for thousands of years on earth
via their avatars never bringing the
battle to the planet themselves so why
do they stay away could something more
powerful be keeping them at bay and
could that something be i don't know the
celestials the celestials not these guys
again
those [ __ ] always in charge of
everything because remember that up
until very recently the celestials had a
very little baby cooking inside of our
planet by the name of tiamet now could
they have been keeping the inead off of
our planet to keep their baby tiamet
safe
that's that's smart right the celestials
if they know they got like a baby inside
the planet you know they let the ass
guardians come because again the
asgardians are just here to drink and
you know have some wars but they keep it
mostly located to norway you know they
plus the
the asgardians they keep away the giants
of yotenheim right they keep away
right they they keep them from taking
over the planet and covering an ice and
possibly killing tiamet right because
the celestials need they need
the dominant life form here to take hold
and like make enough brain power for
tiamat to come to life uh and the
asgardians are helping that because
they're fighting off the the giants and
stuff and like helping life odin's doing
plenty of life spreading around the
planet you know what i mean you know
what i mean uh
but then like when it comes to you know
you have raw and conch you're just
constantly fighting with each other and
we know that raw can turn into the
demigorg so maybe the celestials were
like you guys have got to stay out of
here because if you guys keep coming and
killing all the people like our baby's
never going to get born i like that idea
that even though these bastard
celestials are just trying to blow up
our planet and just using us in some way
they're keeping us safe because they're
like you gotta leave earth alone so that
our baby can get born and then everyone
dies and we don't care but
everything up to that point was pretty
nice pretty nice of them
yeah honestly i i think that asgard
exists to be
the janitors for this list
i like this made this universe and then
like they're like all right asgard you
manage it but all the other gods you
stay out of our business do not touch
anything earth is closed today because
like we know it from the in the comics
this is something that actually happens
during one of the celestial hosts is
that well the celestials find out that
the gods have been so prevalent on earth
for so long right literally walking
amongst us that they were like you can't
do that no more you cannot this cannot
happen like this is our experiment you
guys are messing up our experiment
what's all these religions i don't know
this has to stop do not come back or we
will kick your butts and they the gods
tried to fight the celestials but they
got beat down very hard like they like
they got shut out immediately it's like
what they call the council of gods or
something like or godhood or uh pantheon
right so it's like all the gods will get
together and be like oh i am vishnu oh
hi i'm zeus hi i'm i'm odin and i guess
oh well ra is part of like the pantheon
of gods
uh because i think they immediately they
meet like a separate place right but
you're right yeah mt odin was like look
there's these celestials out there and
they're gonna
you know when the third host ends
they're gonna make a fourth house and
we'll get wiped out we gotta get
together we're gonna build some armor
i'm gonna put the essence of thor in it
we're gonna fight these celestials and
then the celestials come for the fourth
house and they're just like
you're dead
get out of our way we're celestials you
can't stop us what are you crazy
seriously like literally like the like i
like how you brought that up because the
destroyer armor from 4-1 was made
specifically to fight celestials because
after they got absolutely got their
butts kicked from the uh celestial they
were like we have to prepare we gotta
get ready that was embarrassing guys
that was pretty embarrassing on that
what do you guys what were you doing huh
with the rings what i don't
someone do
you got all those arms someone just
something come on and there's also the
panther god bass to consider because in
the comics she too is also part of the
indiana and we've learned that her
champion on earth is the person who
wears the mantle of the black panther so
again another egyptian god who works
through avatar oh that's that's a good
point yeah yeah yet again you're right
empty another god who like can't come to
earth anymore because i would assume
that bass is still alive
still exists yeah right like yeah it's
hard to kill these gods off completely i
mean hella seems to be dead maybe like
she's a god right i'm not dead yeah he
says he's not dead yes he is i'm not uh
but we didn't see her die die right
she's on asgard as the ragnarok happens
so she's maybe dead but probably not
really dead i mean
there could be a chance that
ahmet is hella whoa
whoa
[Applause]
that's the big theory alarm going off oh
my gosh
because that's the only
real female god that we've seen die and
like she needs to come back so hella as
raw would be hella rot you know what i'm
talking about like
you mean hella has ahmed hellas
hella you know that would be awesome if
this last episode is like hella showing
up as amen with an alligator head i'm
gonna
flip out dude bro i would lose my [ __ ]
like that's it's just and like her her
color is green like
mt
should be bricked up watching that [ __ ]
screw these norse [ __ ] they don't
like me i'm going over to egypt baby
let's go
screw you guys i'm getting hit i mean
i'm really hoping that this show
connects
boss to the any end and it's like ugh i
mean how amazing would it be to see like
boss show up and like talk to a black
panther like ah so cool it's inevitable
we're going to see bass talk to black
panther
especially in wakanda forever if they
pass the mantle to someone new like if
boss makes an appearance ooh ooh chills
i would love if chadwick actually
becomes about i would love if that was
like
it's like he becomes a god like
beautiful that would be amazing but why
do we think the uni ed uses avatars like
in general in the mcu okay so i think i
really liked what you were laying out mt
that would be a fun way to explain why
the avatars have to be here is because
they're just too powerful and they can't
get through anymore like maybe the
celestial's even like tricked them into
going to the celestial horopolis uh
because even things like uh you know as
i was thinking about it more like
dormammu right he's able to come through
to earth and he's such a powerful
destructive force and was able to come
through granted he had to have someone
do a spell to like open it up but
eventually he would have come to earth
anyways i like this idea that the
celestials have somehow blocked the
pathway so that these gods can't
physically come to earth anymore because
they're too powerful and they're too
strong what do you think empty the
eternals basically established that the
celestials are the top dogs like they
are
no one's above the celestials they were
there during the big bang they were they
pre-existed the big bang so like it's it
seems that most of the asgardian history
starts with the big bang the celestials
told them or like either
either told them what to do or
imprisoned them somewhere far away so
that they could not interfere with their
affairs i like that i mean it would be
cool too if the demigorg you know if raw
as the demigorg turns out to be
this like tentacle thing that we've been
teased with in what if
and also in you know multiverse of
madness if that's somehow related to raw
somehow and the demigorg like that would
be really cool to see that all come
together honestly like we know that like
the reason why um adam was invented of
course was to to battle kathon and it
was the catholics banishment which is
why the darkhold exists is because he's
writing all this school diary stuff was
about being angry about being kicked out
these technical creatures these these
elder
gods the people that came before
they're gonna very much factor um into
these tentacles
whatever i can't wait to see more of it
and hey head to new rockstarsmerch.com
to grab our latest obsession moon night
shirt it's amazing and we release these
new latest obsession shirts for all of
the big series and films and this one
has been a hot commodity look at this
look at this i'm worried somehow i look
fly look at this all the women have
continued to not talk to me but i have
more confidence to talk to women
but they're they're giving you a second
look they give you a second look in that
shirt give me a second like oh is that
moonlight i'm like no um would you like
to come to conscious throne of blood
it's only going to be available for the
next few weeks so grab one while you can
at
newrockstarsmerch.com because they're
going to go out and once they leave
you're not gonna be able to buy them
again so head on over there immediately
immediately and before we dive into our
bite size questions next some words from
the people that help bring us big
question to you people like masterclass
because with masterclass you can learn
from the world's best minds anytime
anywhere and at your own pace you can
learn how to play basketball from steph
curry improve your cooking skills with
gordon ramsay or learn acting from
samuel l jackson he's nick fury also i
think he got eaten didn't he get eaten
in jaws or something yeah
and with over 100 classes from a range
of world-class instructors that thing
you've always wanted to do is closer
than you think and off-screen producer
zack's mother-in-law has been using
masterclass a ton lately i don't know
how i know that
how do you know all this information
empty oh man um don't start any rumors
please and she's trying to write the
great american novel and they've got
great classes from writers like dan
brown james patterson and even r.l stein
goosebumps scary books couldn't read
them as a kid still can't read them now
and they've got classes on filmmaking
art and business and you can even learn
skateboarding from tony hawk the god
himself that that itself should be worth
the price of admission and the best part
of masterclass is how well produced they
are and they aren't boring lectures
they're interactive lessons shot like a
movie and you'll end up binging them
like a streaming series they promise you
they're so good but highly recommend you
check it out get unlimited access to
every master class and as a big question
audience member you get
15 off an annual membership because we
like to hook it up for you guys because
we love you so go to masterclass.com
bigquestion right now that's
masterclass.com
bigquestion for 15 off masterclass thank
you to masterclass for sponsoring this
video we love you bomba's mission is
simple make the most comfortable clothes
ever and match every item sold with an
equal item donated so when you buy
bombas you are also giving to someone in
need bombas designed their socks shirts
and underwear to be the clothes you
can't wait to put on every day
everything they make is soft seamless
tagless and has a luxuriously cozy feel
they're made from super soft materials
like merino wool pima cotton and even
cashmere oh georgie cashmere which makes
them the perfect cozy layers there's a
pair of bomba socks for everything you
do they come in tons of options like
comfy performance styles for every sport
and activity that keeps you moving
bombas t-shirts are made with thoughtful
design features like invisible seams
soft fabrics and the perfect weight so
they hang
just right bombas underwear has a barely
there feel with second skin support that
might make you forget they're even there
in a good way and did you know that
their socks underwear and t-shirts are
the three most requested clothing items
at homeless shelters that's why bombas
donates one for every item you buy go to
bombas.com bigquestion and get 20 off
your first purchase that's b o m b a s
dot com slash big question for 20 off
bombus.com big question right now it is
time for the bite size questions
what's this oh you found one delicious
delicious where did hella's wolf
companion fenris originally come from
this is from checkers on toast from
twitter checkers on toast delicious well
we first meet fenris and thor ragnarok
when hello uses the eternal flame to
resurrect him along with her army of
berserkers yes fenris was of course her
loyal companion during hela's early days
of conquering the nine realms with her
papa until he decided to that she was
too much of a liability and locked her
away great parenting move odin
this guy what a jerk i mean we were
already talking about about him earlier
but man bad dad bad dad maybe bad dad
mcu is full of bad dads
what a bad dad and every movie he's
always like i don't want to deal with
this problem and then like finally his
sons are getting along he's like i'm
just going to die now
but where did fenris originally come
from right well in the mcu it's kind of
hard to say but what is the history of
fenris in the comics like a lot of
asgardian stuff fenris has a counterpart
in real norse mythology where he is
known by the name of fenrir fenris
sulfur then resulfer i don't know how to
say it fenris sulfur all these norse
words are tough man
and much like his mythological origins
in the comics fenris is the offspring of
loki and the giant anger moda
while fenris usually takes i think i
dated an angry boat
no comment
anger boat is just a mean name to give a
giant a female giant i feel like but
that is from norse mythology too in the
comics and in norse mythology fenris is
the offspring of loki and anger boda
who's a giant uh but it's some weird-ass
sperm brandon i mean i don't ask how it
works it just works okay don't ask
questions well in the comics um fenris
can appear as like a 15 foot tall wolf
or he has the ability to take the form
of a god so he can also kind of take
like a human as form but mostly hangs
out as a wall it also says that like
it's believed loki's the dad like it's
kind of not super clear like he doesn't
want to admit it i don't know so some
weird some weird stuff happens and
fenris gets banished to varheim after he
attacks the goddess aduna who is the
keeper of the golden apples of
immortality uh which these are the
things that like odin needs to eat stay
immortal now this story actually becomes
the basis for the tale of little red
riding hood according to marvel comics
and potentially in our realm as well
according to some historians so the
story of fenris attacking a doona for
the golden apples is like from real
norse mythology it works its way into
marvel comics in both of those worlds in
the marvel world and in our world they
think that like this story is one of the
many stories that leads to creating the
story of little red riding hood because
the main point of that story was to like
stay out of the woods because you'll get
eaten alive right
it's an easy way to tell kids like don't
go around in the woods because you might
die uh a wolf could eat you or a man
could take you and do bad things to you
or appreciate that
gonna cut you out of the stomach and
find you alive he's gonna find your
little bits and pieces he'll be wolf
poop yeah you'll be coming out of his
fenders
daddy
so yeah i love this idea that like
fenris is like the origin of like the
big bad wolf he is the big bad wolf
which is very fun fenris also plays a
role in the prophecy of ragnarok which
is fitting that he should appear in thor
ragnarok according to the prophecy
fenris will be the one who devours odin
again this is in real norse mythology
and in marvel comics so this is probably
why they decide to chain him chain up
fenris on valheim so he can't just like
roam free around there odin has the
dwarves forge the glipe mirror which is
a light but mostly indestructible chain
that becomes stronger the more you
struggle against it fenrir is like kind
of hanging on ballheim and they're like
look we want to put this chain on you
but you'll be fine you can still walk
around he's like okay i don't trust you
guys at all because you've already
banished me to this place he's like if
you're gonna put this chain on me and
this is the glyph near uh and it looks
really light it's very light and he's
like i can break out of this is easy
right but he doesn't trust these guys
he's like if you're gonna put this chain
on me you one of you has to be like have
your hand in my mouth and if i figure
out that i'm locked here i'm gonna bite
your hand and all the gods are like i'm
not doing that i don't want to do that
and this one guy this one god tear is
like okay i'll do it i'll i'll be the
one to step up i'm brave i'll do it he
does it they put the glyph near on
fenrir moves a little and realizes he's
not gonna break it and he's like you son
of a [ __ ] and he bites that hand right
off he just bites that hand off hey what
he warned you he warned you also in the
comics hella once tried to set off
ragnarok herself by freeing fenrir to
kill off odin uh but thor stopped her
before she was able to do it uh but she
knew that like this is part of ragnarok
so i'll just let him go to get things
really popping off but all of that like
comics history doesn't tell us much
about fenris's history in the mcu
given that the timelines are a little
different for how things play out right
hella appears to have existed in a time
well before loki and thor were even
around so we don't really know how
fenris came about in the mcu and he
likely didn't even play any role in
ragnarok that we saw because odin was
already gone so he didn't eat odin he
was there but like you know it's
possible he's still alive along with
hella just kind of like floating around
in space after asgard got destroyed
but there's one thing that you could
consider if if hella comes like way
before the loki and thor that we know
maybe there was another loki in thor
that was alive during her time
uh and she saw them die and she doesn't
bring it up to our loki and thor and
she's because ragnarok is cyclical right
the events of ragnarok keep happening in
a circle in the comics they kind of stop
it thor puts a stop to all of it and
resets the wheel or whatever but i like
this idea that there was another loki in
thor that she maybe knew and she was
like uh i'm not gonna tell these guys
about those guys because they'll just
freak out on me and i don't want to deal
with it yeah
we don't really know where the mcu's
fenris came from but
who knows yeah maybe he's from another
time another universe
who knows yo if if frederis is floating
out in space out there and we are
getting the high evolutionary eyes oh
yeah pick him up oh pick him up and make
him into this a cyborg like the man wolf
man wolf is a big part of um the
mythos of the high evolutionary so let's
go also can you imagine if you're just
like in a spaceship and all of a sudden
you just hit this giant wolf and he's
like
you're like how do we fight a wolf in
space i don't know that's the beginning
of infinity war
instead
fenris is the one who arrives at wakanda
that would be it's oh man that would
equally freak out that would be so cool
that would be really cool but no now it
is time for the box of scraps whoa box
of scraps
of the
william damn it william can't believe
william is an mcu villain now that's so
crazy
he earned it he worked hard
he really did if you could design your
own avatar to walk around on earth what
special features would you give me
you know my instinct is to say if i'm
going to make an avatar for myself i
want to give it like flight powers right
but i think that's a that's a negative i
don't think flying is all it's cracked
up to be
it's going to be cold up there you know
and a big question almost a year ago mt
i think we talked about like the bugs
all the bugs you'd run into right oh
yeah like in the sky just flying around
and like
you know they always make flying seem
fun but unless you can go really fast
it takes forever to get somewhere right
it's not like you're yeah if you're
flying as fast as you can run i mean i
guess if you're flying super fast so
yeah flying's out forget it i don't want
flying that's too much but i would like
a little extra boost to my ground speed
i'd like a little boost of my ground
speed you know what i mean
i'd like to be able to run a little
faster i think laser eyes i don't know
why but i want some laser eyes i think
they would just be useful these are
those would be dope
i think they'd be i mean like hey the
the world runs on fire basically yeah
like i always have a little bit of fun
to go just
but dude it would be hard to hold back
if like you were in an argument with
somebody
and you're just like getting angry like
i sometimes you know i don't want to say
it sometimes i see homelanders point
where it's just like if someone's in
your face
and they're going off and they're jawing
at you you're just like oh yeah you know
what beer right through their head just
like you hate times you just you just
gotta you just gotta immerse yes
so yeah my avatar like a little faster
on the ground speed
uh laser eyes and then boom purple hair
just like straight purple hair ooh like
okay i'd dig that i would have to
exactly it would be fun to have like
colorful hair in the real world but it's
so much upkeep and so much work and your
shower gets ruined from all the hair dye
like
if you could just have naturally purple
hair that would be great that would be
great so basically an anime character
running around
that's my avatar basically my hero
academia character yes what about you
empty
i think that i would probably i just
feel like the world has a really huge
like love deficit problem so like i
would just like have an avatar just like
a love avatar just be like hey man okay
every time you heard him like speak or
something you just felt like comfortable
so we gotta we're gonna crank we're
gonna boost your charm you know your
charm is gonna be boosted and then like
all the way charisma yeah charisma is
all the way to the top do they have
empathy if they have an empathy meter
we'll turn your empathy meter way up yes
and like i i want his superpower to be
like and every time he gave somebody a
hug oh okay they just
felt like
insane's amounts of like comfort and
love i think it might just
rick and morty when he makes like pure
level right and morty stands on whatever
you're allowed to hold on
you're like pure love right if someone
hugs you they they get the sense of like
perfect love and they're just like yes
and then when they stop hugging me they
freak out it's like i feel empty inside
you're gonna be like well you know what
that's gonna be a hundred bucks for the
next hug
now you're a drug dealer for around five
more minutes a hundred bucks that's how
i get them
[Laughter]
well that is it for this episode of big
question again huge thank you to my
brother brandon for joining me on this
episode please follow him
eric on twitter he's a great man an
amazing man follow me at mastertainment
to see me tweet some really weird [ __ ]
and wild theories and follow new
rockstars here on youtube and all our
social media platforms and when you do
just hit that bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and of course please hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to find this amazing
shirt this moonlight shirt and our moon
knight hoodie and all of our just
amazing
merch over there but also if you have
some big questions of your own ask them
on our new rockstars discord server but
only if you're 18 and older just click
that link in the description to join
today but again thank you guys so much
for watching we love you and appreciate
you guys so much so so much and we'll
see you guys next time goodbye bye bye
[Music]
you